[Música]
então deixa deixa de funcionar que está
aqui sim é catarina estava dizendo que
eu venho aqui conta a história de
sucesso mas eu acho que o momento de
maior sucesso da carreira estar aqui
hoje e por isso que eu aceitei o convite
de imediato mesmo sem ver o tema mesmo
de velocidade onde era assim que eu vi
no no sul do ma o técnico embora depois
que comecei a perceber que o tema era
face e ainda por cima tem de falar à
cidade de guimarães a cidade onde nasceu
portugal não é e que tem esse peso tão
grande nessa temática 15 e pra mim risos
eu sugiro a cabeça foi o quinto de ver
com isto eu tenho uma revista digital
como que teria dizia portanto temos tudo
menos reze
ou pelo menos o preenchimento então tudo
coisa um crime mais difícil do que eu
pensava é então fiz o que a gente faz
quando tem que pensar sobre um assunto
que é e alguns vão escrever o nome
a pesquisa que surgiu foi esta que vocês
podem ver aqui isso não é nada inventado
não é manipulado photoshop está mesmo o
google diz que são as raízes e continuar
sempre muito bem o que eu podia falar
com todo mundo natural e não vamos
mentir é muito inspirador mas não tem
nada a ver com o que eu faço
continue você tentar perceber o que é
que eu podia falar sobre isso aí é
tentar distorcer músicas entre uma coisa
e outra coisa mais próxima que encontrei
foi o símbolo do sv que o mal a mãe
parece roriz não valia a pena partilhar
continua a tentar perceber o que é que
eu posso raízes
eu vim de cuba e isso até podia ser mais
ou menos interessantes não tivesse o
foco do inter no entanto o máximo que eu
posso partilhar convosco é que corta
muito talento sai da sociedade mas
também é muito interessante você então
para as 15 do que poderia ser estudando
as raízes e cruzando com esta parte mais
comum a todos nós que é parte da
história e da tradição e que sendo um
menino que sem dúvida alguma é
importante nós mantemos todas essas
técnicas lógico que todos conhecemos a
nossa gastronomia fantástica é todas as
nossas coisas que têm a ver com as
nossas raízes do nosso cliente sejam os
vinhos nas estradas
mas como o que representa acho que isto
é muito bonito mas sendo uma revista
digital falando porém e apontada para o
futuro visto que o que nós fazemos é dar
as notícias da atualidade de certa forma
preparar o que pode ser o futuro e
continuava a não ter muita ambição
porque o que eu faço então continua a
tentar perceber onde é que eu posso
falar sorriso é que eu posso encontrar
isto é 12 anos do tema para se dizer
então volta num clima mais para que o
que é o meu mundo e podem ser esta a
função das raízes no mundo que eu vivo e
não é dessa pesquisa tona para me
incomoda nostalgia imensa que
provavelmente você já virão por aí não é
as peças revendidas a equipes a parar de
prender o fórum o iphone consolação por
fora antigo as aplicações que simulam
estamos a filmar com uma câmera público
a vhs mais um iphone com uma para
estranhíssimo para atender uma loja dos
selinhos portuguesas com um design fazer
lembrar que foi de 1809 que mas com o
edson da mais alta tecnologia lá dentro
e que tem muito muito pouco do essencial
do original ou em outras coisas
diferentes como esta opção do videoclipe
do icann do fmi a câmera é reinventado
como se fosse nos anos 80 basicamente o
que faz disse torcer música tirou a cor
da música enfim que é antigo como se
fosse uma forma de poupar original e
voltar às crises mas não me identifico
todo com esta com esta visão das raízes
da nostalgia com suas quase uma vingança
não é agora todos que estamos a lançar
uma carreira horas para aquelas músicas
que antigamente fugimos não é isso que
não é isso que eu quero é vir para aqui
com capas manipulados num filme é um
filme 2016 2017 e que o défice uma capa
em photoshop a fingir que era antiga e
voltamos às raízes
não é nada disso continua a não ser isso
que vai ter que falar isso não me
interessa partilhar então continue a
tentar perceber o que é que posso final
lá onde estão as nossas raízes e as
raízes do da minha geração da seleção
domingo que cada vez mais passa a sua
vida assim o sport no telemóvel do
esporte em creche e que em média fundo
os estados no estúdio mais recente de
2016 ganhou passa cerca de duas horas e
51 minutos por dia no smarphone esta é
uma realidade que nos últimos anos tem
vindo a evidenciar se cada vez mais como
prova aqui por exemplo as taxas de
crescimentos dos torcedores do flu
ou achas crescimento do número de
brancos ou para não falar nas redes
sociais e percebemos como isso é uma
coisa transversal a toda a nossa cidade
e não simplesmente ter uma conta no
programa ter uma conta no facebook é uma
coisa muito mais cotidiana do que essas
contas comprova o número de vagas
ligados à renda e aí vai muito para além
dos telemóveis vai até a máquina de
lavar vocês sabem que há uma máquina de
lavar que o botão vocês publicam e
passados dias chega a 300 casa pronta e
nem fazer nada então espera por airton
as rimas naves tem muito a ver com isso
e tal símbolo sbt nos mostrava o mundo
cada vez tem menos fios ou seja cada vez
tem menos duas mudanças com raízes nós
parece que nos afastamos a ter essa
idéia do que pode ser responsáveis na
nas opções em português
criar raízes muito raramente é uma coisa
boa raramente alguém destinadas a criar
raízes para dizer que vai fazer uma
coisa boa e novamente foi considerado
tudo isso porque nós temos a idéia de
que tudo que guardas tudo que é sem fios
até o carregamento do funk sem fios é
uma coisa melhor então estamos a diluir
as nossas raízes
então quando elas não irão é que nós
vamos deixar quando estamos a criar
raízes no mundo que o contacto todos os
dias que o infelizmente ao mundo das
notícias que raramente são boas
é o que nós vemos é isso está
acontecendo chifra em quatro anos o
consumo de antidepressivos duplicou
vídeos campanhas falsas para monitorar
leitores pessoas que estão a chegar à
presidência com isso e que são no mínimo
perigosa ou duvidosa anúncio que não se
percebe como é que surgiram as
principais empresas que nós conhecemos
como facebook e google estão sempre
envolvidos em escândalos em escândalos e
acho que nós não precisamos muito bem
então o final declarou que é mais
importante pensar aqui é onde está a
raiz dos problemas porque se nós estamos
a viver num mundo com cada vez menos
reze
mas os problemas continuam a surgir é
preciso tentar perceber qual é a raiz
deste problema e foi esse exercício eu
tentei fazer então acho que o principal
risco estamos a criar
na cabeça seja o primeiro estamos a
criar várias linhas nossa cabeça e othon
tem quando estava preparado isso mais
uma vez cruzando constituído que foi pra
mim feito no seu tempo e que é um
filósofo que diz que o problema dos
factos ecosport tem que ser é uma
relação dos dados interligados que nos
permita queremos como factos exatamente
o que está a acontecer é que estas
interligações entre os pequenos relatos
estão a desaparecer porque as pessoas
nem sequer compreender que o que estão a
fazer peça enquanto vocês sabem com
exatidão o que significa enviar uma
mensagem no facebook
ninguém nem eu porque nós pensamos na
internet pensamos nisso pensamos à luz
em wifi cac magicamente no ar
pensamos em muito forte sobre coisas no
outro dia vi um anúncio num telemóvel em
que uma pessoa que ama os braços e voa
toda a nossa imagem que tem muito a ver
com a primeira ligação o terreno
primeira ligação material mas isso tem
de tudo pra um anô é pensarmos em tanguá
genro interessante pensar nisto
nós vamos ter um cláudio pra falar da
computação
mas qual lançou mais de computadores
ligados em rede como física convidado
nisso que nós claramente temos noção
nós quando pensamos em riso hoje em dia
é a forma que mais usa percebemos as
raízes é quando vamos na rua e algumas
raízes de uma árvore fez levantar um
passo aí nós tropeçamos e aí percebemos
que há afinal harris não é mais o que
mesmo assim não há sorte com um copo e
eu estamos afinal quando é que nós
tropeçamos nas raízes no mundo digital
fui falar disto não é que afinal de
contas a internet não anda no ar e são
estes carros que estão aqui estão mesmo
as ligações reais por item que existia
internet
como podem ver aqui em portugal há uma
série de deus em nós para que vocês
acreditem que não fizesse essa é a
claudia também não há propriamente na
quadra somente data center 19 na enorme
está na covilhã ea internet como se isso
não passar no ar foi neste caso gigantes
e atravessam praia que são el rey fase
podia fazer qualquer um interessado mas
não é que estão os riscos disse eu acho
que os principais requisitos ser criados
na nossa cabeça vão ser criadas nossa
cabeça de várias formas uma delas o
chile por falar nas redes sociais nós
o aumento nos relacionávamos em
comunidades e criar um dos reis forte
com as pessoas com quem nos relacionamos
cada vez mais na rua assinamos com
pessoas nas redes sociais e que faz a
criar condições mais fracas as chamadas
week tais ligações fracas isso
antigamente as condições fracas eram os
colegas de trabalho os colegas de escola
por exemplo hoje em dia as condições
fracas podem ficar a quilômetros e
quilômetros e quilômetros de distância
em que as relações fortes sejam
realmente influenciadas por isso
encerrou em alguns casos com por exemplo
os casamentos de pessoas do mesmo sexo
aumentaram imenso com o surgimento da
internet graças ao conhecimento pessoas
online e aplicações como rider
eu dou o exemplo da função na praça
tahrir e uma história que encontrou o
jurista paulo moura que todo mundo
achava que tava vendo uma revolução na
praça tahrir
- as pessoas que enviam 500 metros da
praça que nunca tinha ouvido falar do
que estava a falar tanto é preciso
pensar neste domingo um exemplo também é
fiel ao que aconteceu há três dias que
essas moções fracas têm um problema que
nós não conseguimos criar empatia com as
pessoas simplesmente porque nós
conhecemos
eu se esta pessoa para em dois anos no
twitter e só dois dias e fiquei a saber
qual tinha problemas de saúde e que
agora está a cadeira de rodas
tanto imagine ter uma conversa
mobilidade com esta pessoa em causa de
uma opinião completamente quando
ensinava eu não faço a mínima ideia
porque tudo que eu vá sobre ela é o seu
recado no twitter e pouco mais
outro nos pontos onde criamos raízes na
forma como nós conseguimos a informação
e estou mais duas notícias do shift
também e possamos dizer que 62% das
pessoas hoje em dia ao teste das
informações nas redes sociais
sob pressão dos quais fazendo com muita
freqüência e nem quero imaginar é é a
porcentagem de pessoas que só fazem nas
redes sociais e significa que as nossas
reis informativas
ou seja nos centramos nossas raízes para
buscar a informação é cada vez mais
neste mundo há no ar numa e nessas
revisões fracas o que significa que em
vez de estarmos a conseguir informação
nos jornais mas todos nós que é mais ou
menos como se uma rede interconectada
das coisas que nós conseguimos conceber
hoje em dia estamos dependentes dessas
redes
o círculo em torno de poucas pessoas
por exemplo o cristiano ronaldo é um
exemplo disso é de 122 mil seguidores no
facebook se eu disser uma informação de
sumir por 122 mil as pessoas mais
aumento e as discussões não são
interconectados com podem ver isto é um
exemplo real uma visualização da
discussão sobre os pacotes de explosivos
que foram entregues agora na américa 3 a
4 meses e é perfeitamente visível com
uma dicção já 34 pontos de discussão mal
se interconectam índice ou seja há
muitas situações muitas funções fracas
geram punição na discussão e raramente é
quebrado este filtro bolha conectado
filtro bolhas geralmente as pessoas
acabam em consultar na internet porque é
isso que acontece na internet
tanto que nos anos 90 um advogado
chamado chamado mike goodridge crioula
gobbi diz que uma discussão na internet
acaba quando alguém comparar o outro
veículo era tal não é a probabilidade de
alguém comprar o outro a ir para outro
do outro dos luta das provas de que isto
é acabam sempre executar suas verbas
assunto é um termo que surgiu muito
recentemente nós estamos falando de um
chip que é o batismo que é quando a
organizar 11 propõe um tema de discussão
a outra pessoa dizer há mais riscos não
fala sul
a polícia pode ser outra coisa qualquer
escolheu um tema e essa é uma forma de
fugir o assunto e não para discussão a
ser profunda
isto leva-nos a uma individualização ó
que o que chamam de qualidade da nossa
presença da nossa forma de estar e que a
comparação entre o fígado horizontal
também possuirão portugal das células
colors os laicos goste ambição dos
favoritos o fato do corpo desaparece ser
o mais popular o mais interativo com
mais mais com mais enquanto que no
horizontal por muito chato que fosse de
vez em quando vamos com isso quer ao
menos 15 ensinar qualquer coisa hoje
inicial ficou mais um mais um mais
entendemos a hiper na organização e para
a organização leva filmes como estes
provavelmente conhecem que é uma onda de
insegurança que mostra com todas as
fotografias são tiradas naquela região
do alasca caiu são todas iguais e não
hesita eu acho que eu poderia acontecer
se nós procuramos mexe técnico mas
também sobre o momento uma coisa assim
vamos perceber que todas as fotografias
são exatamente iguais e ninguém está
de cometer este erro por assim dizer um
ano enquanto que em breve a noite e
tiraram o fotografar o workshow portugal
aicep vai aprender não queria ser mais
um em vila isabel vai ficar ligado a
outro ponto que o prêmio também é mãe de
santo que é é nós procuramos muito saber
qual é a rotina do sião tremulará outras
500 páginas por dia trabalhando aceitar
aquelas coisas todas
ninguém pensa que os jogos não fez
absolutamente nada sozinho e não fez
nada são uma equipa de programadores
imensa e que sofriam imensa não tinha
uma rotina como esta têm uma rotina
completamente a partida e com qualquer
um nós com qualquer pessoa que sofremos
e aveia
portanto esta verticalidade três filhos
todos o próximo se eu entrevistei todas
as rotinas manhã prefeita prometeu levar
grande sítio e um problema é o que para
mim é o maior problema nestas o
professor superficialização
individualização do consumo de
informação das condições pessoais do
disso é que nós não precisamos as raízes
do sistema em que vivemos não fazemos a
mínima idéia
nós compramos uma camisola nem queremos
terminar daquela foi feita e muito
provavelmente o que está a acontecer é
que são as realidades que com alguma
informação alguma investigação
conseguimos perceber é que a nossa
camisola está a ser altamente poluente a
ser responsável por pessoas estranhas
escravizadas no outro lado do mundo e
isso para nós acaba por entrar no nosso
dia a dia
nossa primeira das pessoas na somália
podem entrega quando ela se metem um
bote e programas estão fugidos e nós
fingimos que muitos sabem o que está com
o celular
mas nossa janeiro a 15 nós próprios
temos nosso consumo é nada disso
o pensar que enquanto nós achamos que a
internet está a ser desenvolvida entre
as velocidades mais rápidas de internet
para que nós possamos no lugar e ver os
nossos vídeos de tênis à vontade não
tudo está sendo desenvolvido por que os
traders na bolsa podem comparar alguns
trocam milhões milhões se conseguir uma
ligação mais rápida do que faz
desenvolver a internet
nós somos nós a nossa posição é termos
um mundo mais sustentável nós temos o
melhor nas apple para o nerinho e alguns
culparam nerin
outro exemplo do que daquilo que vos
digo é que esta verticalidade esta forma
de
este feedback positivo não é ético o
estrago se inscrever no processo que se
eu voltar a dizer mal do programa que
não faz sentido mas levamos propondo às
vezes sem retorno e ea é preciso
visualizar os dados por perceber o que é
a realidade que queremos construir com a
realidade e trouxemos ele mora e onde
eram os professores idéia ali mora foi
posto à venda nos anos 70 e e tecnologia
muito objectivamente a capacidade
transitórios por transitar com o
processador e aumentar sempre a cada
dois anos
isso aconteceu de fato aconteceu também
foi com a indústria farmacêutica
aconteceu precisamente do filme versa
surpresa também estava a aumentar a
capacidade de inovação na indústria
farmacêutica está a baixar ao mesmo
tempo tentamos desenvolver tecnologia
para eu queria dizer isso para que
possamos pensar todos os dias nós
janeiro que o mesmo quando vemos as
raízes elas estão lá são invisíveis
subliminar nós criamos em crer
temos a informar para assinar tudo isto
o risco que nós criamos
são pessoas são aprendizagens as redes
são involuntárias noé
vocês vão ficar como opinião sobre mim
então fica como o contato dos amores nós
estamos a criar entre nós
inicialmente pensava-se que os fatos não
tiveram uma raiz é difícil nós
percebemos é que classificaram como é
chegar a uma determinada conclusão e é
por essa consciência dos reis nós temos
que ter para que mensagens como um
incentivo ao ódio ou a violência
são mensagens muito mais simples que são
muito menos em realmente não não sou se
dão conta da facilidade trouxe uma
situação da encosta no entanto gosta
especialmente que puderem vão ler
chama-se visão de especialistas que eu
acho que traduz muito bem esta idéia e
depois quer dizer que nós estamos aqui
serei pré candidatos ou trocar de
marchas e revistas mas a falta de
horizontalidade da falta de diversidade
da nossa do nosso cotidiano faz com que
nós não sejamos bons humanos precisamos
fazer cada vez melhor cia ou seja cada
vez menos humanos
então é importante voltar a pensar nisso
porque é importante até para os
políticos por exemplo sejam pessoas boas
humanas e que tenham todas as condições
que nós queremos é essa frase é de um
artigo se for pra você explicar a emoção
entre a minha toca o shift os homens
gostam mais
construir preservar ou seja usar mas
gosto mais do próximo avanço tecnológico
do conversa que ele está realmente fazer
bem ao ganhar ou seja o que for e os
clientes e começará no final estamos
permanentemente a piada isso precisamos
garantir que o sol ou seja a oferta está
sendo feita
[Música]
[Aplausos]